あれ、ピントがここに合ってんだよな〜
いやいやいやいやいや
ピントが完全に後ろに合ってんだよな〜
なぜ私が心霊スポットに行くかと言いますと
ま、結局は怖いものを見たいんですよねw
だからなんでピント後ろに合う〜？
俺に合ってよ。マジで怖ーんだけど
霊感があるわけじゃないんで〜
怖いもの見たさでついつい行っちゃうんですけども
あの、先日
後輩と行った愛知県と静岡の
間のトンネルの動画、あったと思うんですけども
あれの後編
こんにちは
ご覧になられたでしょうか？
何分だったか忘れたんですけど〜
そもそも車のフロントライトが急に消える時点でおかしいと思うべきだったんですけど〜
コメント欄とかで見て、
おかしな場所があるな、と思いまして
まあそれがこちらなんですけども
5分34秒、もう一度ご覧いただきましょう
どうぞっ！
この後っ！この後っ！
ウアー⤴︎
えー、わかりましたでしょうか
ビニール袋がガサガサっとなった後、
明らかにっ僕でもなく
後輩君でもない
別の方の声が
入って、います...
まぁ、ひょっとしたら何か別の声じゃないかとか、
僕の声かMASAYA
後輩の声が入ってただけなんじゃねぇか。って
僕思ってあまり気にしてなかったんですけども。
あの、はっきりと「そうじゃない」ってことを最近ちょっと
知ってしまいまして。
で、あの、水溜まりボンドの、カンタからちょっと、
連絡が来て、
水溜まりボンドの、ＢGMを創ってくれてるぅ
GTKさんって方がいるんですけども、
その方がですねぇ、
なんか先日、心霊動画の声
声の部分を、音声分析して下さったらしいです。
その音声分析していただいた結果、
誰の声でもないという結論に至ったらしいです。
いや、わざわざ音声分析するのも面白いんですけど
なんか、動画もつくってくださったみたいなので
一回見てみましょうか。
どうぞっ
もう一回見てみましょう。
ごめんなさい。見方がわかんないんですけどもぉ。
たぶん。
音声的に言うと。
なんかこのうめき声の場所。
音的に言うと。
僕の声でもないしぃ。MASAYAの声でもない。
あそこにいた誰の声でもない。という・・・
結論に至ったらしいです。
あぁ
正直、この心霊スポットに、行った後
特に何も、
起きてないんですけど、
まぁ風邪を引いたくらいかな
心霊スポットに行った次の日、結構風邪引いちゃって
咳とか結構出たんですけども
今はもう、治って、大丈夫です
まぁこうやって見返してみると、
女の人の声が入っていて
誰の声でもなかったっていう検証結果も出たので
イイネ！
まぁ良くはないww良くはないんですけど
はい、というわけで今回ですね
音声検証の結果、あれは誰の声でもなかったっていうことが
分かってしまったんですけども
えーあそこ、まぁ結構、心霊スポットふざけて行くとこじゃないんですけども
まぁこういうことが起きてしまったということで
引き続き
やばいちょっと待って、ガムテープ燃えてね？！
待って待ってww燃えてる燃えてる待ってやばいやばい
やばいやばい、えっ、はいっというわけで
ちょっとあの結構、燃えてますけどけども
えー心霊スポット行くときは皆さんもお気を付けて
行ってください